look there's no question this is a huge
moment for the labor party Jeremy corbyn
has been a labor MP for 40 years he's a
former leader just a few years ago
secure starmer was calling him a friend
he campaigned for him to be prime
minister well now they are severing ties
saying he's not even fit to stand for
the party at the next general election
so a big moment in the end of motion
pass reasonably easily here at Labor's
headquarters it was the NEC the ruling
body that voted on it in the end it was
22 to 12 there were some Jeremy corbyn
back is in the room some of the unions
momentum of course so now this is rubber
stamped it's signed off this is party
policy Jeremy corbyn will not stand at
the next general election it'd be
interesting to see of course how he
responds will he run as an independent
will he try to challenge this in some
way maybe in the courts if that's
possible these are questions that I did
put to him yesterday we saw him outside
Parliament he was speaking it's an event
in Parliament Square this is what he
said then
can we just very quickly ask you if
you're thinking of standing as an
independent Mr Corbin very much I'm
going to the demonstration against the
immigration bill and I suggest you
report that too we are reporting it it
will take 10 seconds
I just want to talk to you for 10
seconds about your future as a language
thank you very much
okay
so you can see there Jeremy corbyn uh
tight-lipped on what his next steps are
I was just speaking in the building
behind me some of Labor's leadership
team are there including Shabana Mahmoud
who is the campaign uh coordinator for
labor she put her name to this motion as
well and I put a few questions to her on
what's just happened on whether this is
a really significant moment for the
labor party she said it is she also said
Jeremy corbyn brought this on himself by
some of his actions and in particular
the way that he spoke about the party's
anti-Semitism problem I did ask her as
well she used to be a colleague she
served under Jeremy corbyn she told
voters
um to make him prime minister as many
labor MPS did does she have a direct
message for him now that he's been cast
aside by his party she said no not
really this decision speaks for itself
so you can see now this is really a
pretty ruthless moment I think it's fair
to say from the labor party they have
really just cut ties with Jeremy corbyn
have forgotten his years of service in
pursuit of one thing they want to win
the next general election they want to
get those voters back that deserted them
in 2019 uh I think the question now is
what has Jeremy corbyn going to do and
we may hear from him in the next few
days he's going to have to make a
decision is he going to stand against
the party that he has served for so many
years
Liz thank you